[Music]
party favor has been a darling of the
dance scene since 2014 and 2022 is going
to be a big year his new song you just
heard it superhuman with k-flay is out
now and he's taking over hakkasan this
friday welcome buddy good to see you
it's good to be here thank you so much
for having me so the song is awesome how
did it come together how did you and k
play start working together we had been
going back and forth on uh you know
doing a song together i love her work
she's super talented and uh we were
sending stuff back and forth she sent me
a demo of her singing over this guitar
loop that uh her and her friend had done
and i was driving and i i stopped the
car i actually had to pull over i was on
freeway in l.a if you know the
freelancers are like it's kind of crazy
and i legit legitimately was no joke i
pulled over and i was like
this is a song i knew it and i drove
straight home and i started working on
it and made the whole bones of this
record that night it was just
it came just like that yeah and i love
that you pulled over too you always
wonder why someone's pulled over on the
side of the road like what's that person
doing their writing hit song this is
what they're doing yeah so i gotta ask
the name the backstory on the name yes
uh the name uh i started the name uh in
college because we were throwing college
parties and my buddy uh and and djing
and you know at the time all we wanted
to do was party and have a good time and
uh
i didn't think too much about it it just
was kind of like i want to be
the party guy the party person you know
and so and here we are you know and
still still at parties so what did you
want to do because i mean what was your
your career path in college and growing
up what was your career path man when i
was young i wanted to be an actor so uh
and then that translated into wanting to
be uh in film and in the film industry
uh and so that's what was that was my
plan i was i wanted to work in film and
tv and you know and somehow i ended up
working into music and you know where
you are now yeah it was just so awesome
yeah so with hakasan coming up on friday
what is your job basically
yeah yeah it's it's it's easy stuff you
could do it you got the look you got the
vibe you got the energy well i got
dressed nicer though for you i know i
want to wear a hat man this is the look
i want to come and look like you you've
got the look come on come on with
hakasan on friday before you start your
show and everything do you have like a
pre-show ritual that you go through to
kind of get your mindset going
uh you know it's funny i'm a person i
get really anxious so i don't get really
nervous anymore but uh i get so i like
to
get to the club like five minutes before
i'm supposed to go on so i really yeah i
don't like to sit there and look around
because i start i start wanting to play
and like you know get angsty so uh for
me the ritual is literally just like a
little zen moment and then it's like
we're on stage now we're looking at some
footage here yeah this is i think this
was actually shot by by our executive
producer selena she was at one of her
shows and she was right there vip right
there up there with you do fans get that
close to you when you're performing or
did she paid a lot of money for this
video that's a good spot right there huh
yeah look at i even turned around and
waved to her yeah you got a wave and
everything yeah that's a marquee day
club that's always a blast over there
you know uh we luckily get to be up
there with the fans blowing and
and in the shade so you know it's a
party man yeah it's it's a party so i
want to hit you up so i got rapid fire
music preference quiz and i throw some
questions your way and just give me like
the first song that pops in your mind
okay okay because i mean you're a music
expert yes best song to drive to
uh right now uh the new joji and bonobo
song i don't know why what it's called
but it's it's it's it's very vibrant
that's one yes okay okay uh best workout
song
oh uh best workout song probably uh
anything about radiance machine bulls on
parade oh i get you going okay uh uh
with valentine's day coming up best song
to play during a romantic dinner
oh uh
uh i'm gonna go with oh uh
not you got me on the spot here
i'm gonna go with a romantic dinner um
candles
intimate evening uh the way you look
tonight that's good yes that's good okay
last one best song to play in the club
in the club
that's the go-to if you ever are in a
situation where you're like okay the
crowd's just not vibing or whatever
in the club that's your goat you've got
to queue up you have right everybody
knows it everybody knows you're awesome
i really appreciate it thanks for having
me good to have you back in here party
favors new single superhuman with k-play
is out now and you can see him at
hakkasan february 3rd and the 25th plus
he'll be at marquee day club on may 8th
with side piece which is your side
project right that's the side project
appreciate it brother thank you thank
you